eh los chimeneas afectados por el
conflicto recibieron el domingo raciones
de alimentos proporcionadas por una ong
local la guerra civil que empezó en 2014
ha llevado el país al borde de la
hambruna y ha creado uno de los peores
desastres humanitarios del mundo sin
embargo el acuerdo de tregua del 2 de
marzo trajo una relativa calma en el
país pero un mes después de la
expiración de esta tregua Naciones
Unidas se dice gravemente preocupada por
la seguridad de los civiles
reiteramos los llamamientos del
secretario general de la ONU que ha
dicho que es hora de que las fuerzas
gubernamentales y sus aliados junto con
las fuerzas de danzar a la y sus
partidarios Internacionales elijan La
Paz para siempre
pero la guerra civil no es la única
dificultad a la raíz de esta grave
crisis humanitaria el comité
Internacional de la Cruz Roja analiza
que la triple amenaza del cambio
climático o los conflictos y las
emergencias sanitarias formaría una
mezcla mortal para los más vulnerables
en entornos frágiles
estamos viendo los graves efectos
agravados de los crecientes riesgos
climáticos y de los conflictos armados
desde Afganistán hasta somalia desde
Mali hasta yemen nuestro trabajo en
estos lugares ayuda a las personas a
hacer frente a la crisis climática pero
los actores humanitarios no pueden
responder solos a la multitud de
desafíos
el conflicto en yemen llama tú a más de
150.000 personas con más de 3 millones
de desplazados internos y dos tercios de
la población dependiente de la ayuda
alimentaria para sobrevivir